for for all all y'all jama aaron bridget  be honest  who is the bigger diva on set alex or  keanu  i can't answer that until i know if the  movie has  been locked and if there's a chance i  could get cut out  she's like wait no i  i have heard though honestly that both  of y'all are just  such delights to work with you're so  respectful you're so kind you go out of  your way  that's honestly why i felt bold enough  to ask the question um  but that's so awesome like just people  that have been in the business and you  you know  um done what you've done with your  career it's it's very easy for people to  drink their own kool-aid we all know  those people  but you still realize you're not on a  different level i think i feel like a  lot of people that gets lost on do you  agree  oh everyone's afraid i'm the only one  not afraid to get fired or something no  let's be real let's be real okay how it  was was we had to brush keanu's hair  every day  so diva  [Music]  you